hey um you've had
you had such a long association with one
team in this league which is i guess
kind of unique now
what how hard was that decision and what
led to it
um no like you said you know spending
the
my first nine years in the league uh
with cleveland cavaliers and um
obviously being dropped there at 19 and
winning a championship
and having a lot of success but also
going through the process of what it
takes to
be at the mountaintop um of course it's
uh
it's tough but uh you know that's part
of chapter in life i think uh
in life you go through different phases
different chapters it's like a book so
um you know i had an amazing opportunity
to be able to play for a franchise for
nine years and
you know dan gilbert and you know the
whole staff
and the front office and everyone was a
part of that to give me the opportunity
to
you know play that many years and
believe in me uh you know i appreciate
that but
you know it's a business and you know i
think uh you know this was the best
decision for me in my career and the
point that i'm at to uh
you know join a team that's trying to do
something special and you know for me
being the four
straight finals and winning a
championship and knowing what they're
trying to achieve and they want to go to
promise land if i could come here and
you know help be a part of that and get
them over over that hump
you know that's uh that'd be an honor
adam himmelsbach
hey tristan uh can you kind of walk us
through a little bit the process like
obviously at what point the
celtics reached out to you and what they
kind of described
their vision to you of how they feel
like you can fit in here and
why you chose that this was the best
place for you yeah
i think uh a coach always told me um
usually the team that you uh have a lot
of success against or beat up against
a lot in uh in years in the playoffs
they usually uh
want you to join their side when you
when you're available or when you become
a free agent so um
you know i've always heard the rumblings
about uh ramblings about uh
you know celtics interested in me and
you know
i got a good relationship with a you
know with jayla i've known jalen since
he's first got drafted and
you know jt uh you know he's we've
talked and he's reached out to me
uh you know after the deadline and and
all that stuff about coming to join them
so
um you know when francis started you
know it's not july 1st it was december
1st or whatever the day was
um or november whatever it is i'm so
confused with my days because
nothing's in nba order anymore but um
you know coach
i mean mr ainge called me um
[Music]
around you know around them was able to
give those phone calls and
you know he told me about how much you
know he loves my game and how much
you know i could be a great piece of
this team and a missing piece to what
they're trying to accomplish
and you know the fact that you know
kemba reached out to me and i've known
kemba since
we both played in high school when he
was at rice on that same bendix so i've
had relationships with all these guys
and
and you know for them to be you know
felt like i was wanted and felt like you
know they really want me to be a part of
what they're trying to accomplish
uh it was a pretty uh easy decision
jared weiss hey tristan you were just
talking about
trying to help this team get over the
top as someone who's been to the finals
a bunch of times and has even knocked
this team out of the conference finals a
bunch of times
can you kind of elaborate on what the
difference is between
getting to the conference finals and
actually getting over that hump and even
winning the championship
i mean i think every every year it's
different i think um
depends on it's all about the matchup
right so i think for this team
will really attract me to the celtics is
that how how young
and talented these guys are i mean you
know jaylen jason even smart
uh you know how young they are and how
talented are such a young age you know
i always remember when uh kyrie and
gordon were out
and you know you had terry and you had
you know all these young guys you had
tatum he was a rookie uh
jb he was i think second year maybe
third year i can't remember
and then smart uh very similar third
fourth year
them to take us to a game seven uh at
such a young age is that's a promising
ball club so
um i think you know with my
experience and what i who i've been
around you know playing with lebron and
learning you know day in and day out you
know what he puts in and how he punches
the clock and
almost trusting that whole process i
know it's such a cliche thing to say
because joanna lambie
and then the sixers basically use it
till they turn black and blue in terms
of trust the process
but that's what it really is and i think
you know
it's very little you know it's whether
it's a couple possessions or a key stop
in the conference files that can get you
to the finals and i think it's those
little things that
you know hopefully i can come in and be
the difference maker
to help this team get to you know where
they want to get to
john corrales
hey tristan danny age the other day
specifically mentioned that you were on
that team
that came back from down 3-1 to beat the
warriors
uh he seemed to to really focus on that
as
one of the reasons why you would help
this team from a
leadership standpoint can you maybe
explain
what what he's looking for in that
yeah i think my experience uh you know
being a part of coming back from 3-1 and
being
a big part of that and having big games
in those moments
i think uh it could help a lot with
these guys because
you know being down 3-1 you know
everyone will say
no one in anybody has ever done it the
golden state war is the best team in nba
history
to hear all that but for our group to
stick together and i think the key for
for our ball club at that moment and
that time period was that
how close together we were i think um
our relationship was so tight off the
court
that when we were down 3-1 you know
people counted us off but you know that
that same night when we were
you know the game was over we all text
each other and said you know
we think we can win this with a series
so if we win game five we win the series
and you know lebron text everyone said
you know if you don't think we have a
chance to
to win game five or win this series and
don't come on the plane and that's
something that
as a leader and a guy to a young guy
hearing your leader say that and how
much he believes in this ball club
his ball club it says a lot and it
almost gave
the guys that maybe weren't sure if we
could actually do it it gave them faith
and hope and
experience that you know it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to be a
part of something like that so for me to
be able to
you know share my wisdom from what i
learned from brian
to pass down to these guys it's what the
nba is about i think this is a
fraternity and
and whenever you have the chance to play
with greatness or you know one of the
best players i ever play our game
you always want to pass down the wisdoms
so if i can pass wisdom down uh
you know jt or jalen then he's going to
pass it down to the next young guys that
are coming
up that's how you keep the cycle going
gary washburn hey christian
um first of all you've been in the
league team almost 10 years now how does
your body feel
still only 29 have you reached your peak
yet
and what have you done over the last few
years to improve your free throw
shooting your offensive game
seems like you've really polished those
skills yeah i know um
i mean at 29 i'm still a young pup in
this game i think
i think everyone gets so used to you
know seeing me and the cavaliers on tv
at a high level people almost forget
that
you know he was he was just a young
fellow playing with these you know these
guys in their
you know prime or end of their prime you
know you know with my teammates that
were all over
you know 32 and i was you know 25 26
kyrie was the same way people always
think you know we're actually older than
we are but
you know i guess it's the luxury of
being a one-and-done guy you you play in
nba a little earlier but uh my body
feels great
you know uh i have a lot of room to grow
and like you said gary
you know you've seen the growth in my
game every year and that's what i want
to continue to do and continue to do
here with the celtics so
i feel great you know have time off of
course uh
during that those five six seven months
however long it was
um became my groundhog day but you know
it was on the court
and in the weight room taking care of my
body um just you know getting prepared
for this and i think for me i could
bring a
breath of fresh air because you know
these guys didn't have an off season and
for me having a
having a long off season bring that
extra juice to kind of fire guys up
brian rob
hey tristan uh just wanted to see um if
you've
been able to talk with brad much yet in
terms of what he kind of envisions for
your role in the court and where
typically you think you'll be able to
help this team the most based on what
you you know seems that they have so far
now coach stevens meeting him talked and
i think uh you know he said everything
that i was expecting for him to say in
terms of just
you know with this ball club i could
just be myself just be myself come out
and
and you know of course you know share my
wisdom whether the good stuff or the bad
stuff that i've
seen or been around to help these guys
continue to grow to become better pros
and bring us together the team in terms
of leadership-wise but in terms of
offensively defensively bringing that
energy i think my energy's gonna ignite
the team and
that's what he was saying to me that you
know you know i got to be the motor that
jumpstarts the team and get us going so
uh you know that's i've always had that
role
and you know i've been like that since
day one so coming in
you know i'm gonna play harder than the
big against that i'm going against where
i'm playing against play harder than
them and
you know that that's contagious and i
think um you know everyone around the
league
knows how value that how valuable that
is so
you know just being myself and um i
think it's worked out pretty well for me
and i think
you know for this ball club it can help
them a lot john corrales
tristan you obviously played a lot with
one of the greatest players ever
um and now you're you're playing the
greatest player ever
that's fair um
now you're playing with uh a guy
in jason tatum that that's looking to
make a leap into
you know an mvp type conversation what
can you
what knowledge can you impart on on
jason
after having seen what it takes to
achieve that level of greatness in the
locker room
i think for jt uh just keep working just
keep your head
you know just in the gym and i you know
jt has been in here every day working
hard working on this game and i think
you know since his rookie year and in
those playoffs
everyone saw the oozing potential and
saw that you know this kid has what it
takes to be an mvp conversation and
and this season i mean even last season
before before the pandemic hit
he was you know that game in utah in
in in la the way he was playing and i
watched a lot of celtics games so
the way he was playing at a high level
he was putting himself in that
conversation so i
i expect for it to keep going like that
and trending in that direction so
my advice to him is you know whatever
you're doing keep doing you know
keep working on your game keep watching
film whatever's been working for you
keep doing that
and also you know never be afraid to you
know
speak up if you see something that's not
right you've earned the right with this
ball club
to speak up and say your mind you know
right from wrong and and your type of
guy i always preach that
you know if your got a punches in the
clock and does the right things every
day
you earn the right to to to to to
light a fire under your teammate's ass
and or call them out and because we all
expect the
best from each other we want i want
jason to be the best jason he can be and
he wants
me to be the best christian i can be and
that's what that's what
real brotherhood that's what leadership
is about and that's how you take your
game to the next level because
you know playing lebron you know he'll
call it he'll call us out and you don't
want us to be better but we'll hold him
accountable the same way and
once you're able to do that and your
teammates respect that that's when you
know your game goes to another level
final question for tristan chris ryan
hey tristan wondering you know in what
ways specifically you think you can
you bring this team over the top
particularly in regards to the
physicality
and toughness yeah i know definitely
physicality and toughness i think uh you
know smart is
you know as a bulldog and he's done a
great job you know since he's come here
day one not backing down from
anyone i think he's done that awesome at
the guard position
i think for me now at the big position
bringing that same energy and
you know playing against you guys you
guys seen or saw me enough
to see how how i play and i'm gonna play
the exact same way when i was in a
cleveland cavalier jersey playing you
guys in the playoffs or in the regular
season
i'mma bring that same greatness and
toughness and you know you saw in the
miami series
you know um you know the bigs are their
bigs are playing at a high level and
playing well so for me it's to come in
there and
you know try to slow those guys down and
make it tough for them and
you know like like big perk would say
laid out wood
all right we're gonna wrap it up right
there thanks tristan yep thank you guys